alejandra my man look at sharp you came
in correct huh fresh cut this guy got
the glasses get a jet suit on business
dog right how old are you
hey you love it house one already love
it love it I love what you do what were
you doing in there I gave them now 100 I
have to extend big fan of yours thank
you
so I kind of wanted to have them
interview you for like 10 minutes that
you could do a a little bit of a video
yeah
interview with you no problem coming up
with your side YouTube channel
opening with your brand oh oh a hundred
bucks less come on ten years old
sorry life lessons hopefully somebody
you know was on for 100 do me a favor
never give life lessons that you haven't
actually lived got it because that's
going to be the tough part I'll listen
to your life lessons because I'm
actually very curious what's going on in
the mindset of a 7 to 12 year old but I
won't listen to you giving me advice
about things that you haven't
experienced yet yeah got it that is that
little piece of advice is the difference
that I believe between you winning and
you losing because my belief and I'm
watching some of this 12 14 16 year old
stuff happening there's a lot of that
happening and a lot of it's happening
from mom and dad feeding and the
cynicism and the pushback from the
audience is pretty aggressive and it's
not a winning formula so keep it in mind
yeah everything everything we talked
about experience experiences so that's a
love it part of why I teach them is that
you have
why did you tag along at the end of
every video learn learn explore and most
of all have fun good for you my man
that's awesome okay so the first
question I was gonna and I was your son
and I'm studying a business yep what
advice would you give that's a very very
solid opening question I would actually
look at what you were into like so
you've got this business hustle down
right but like are you playing video
games
collecting Pokemon do you like baseball
I would look I would know you since you
were my son and I would look at
everything that you're interested in and
the first piece of advice I'd give you
is do something around that right so I
think because for example for me because
I loved baseball as a kid the baseball
card business came very natural to me
because it's what I loved the thing that
most people don't understand is that it
takes hard work and when you're a little
kid when I was a little kid like there's
so many other things that all your other
friends are doing so many other things
that you could be doing they're still in
that stage where there's so many other
things you want to be doing so the only
way to really maintain it is to actually
do it around something you love so my
first pick so like for example let me
reverse this on you what do you love
besides business and things that make
sure what else are you into karate great
so to me karate would be a very
interesting thing to look at so what
would that be should we start a karate
fashion brand right like the way Under
Armour and Nike roll and like do you
want to go that route do we want to make
karate content do you want to be we want
to make a little karate figurine in Asia
and produce it and sell it on eBay we
would reverse-engineer karate we would
lay out 10 15 things you could do then I
would let you pick it because I'd want
it to be your decision
and then you'd roll okay the next
question I'm going to ask you is that
that you have any regrets in your life
as a teenager it's a very good question
there little good um the reviews doesn't
see how I answer this this will make
more sense to you along the way I was so
committed to my business and my business
life at 14 15 16 17 18 and I mean so
committed every Friday after school I
would go to the dollar store or the mall
buy stuff to sell at baseball card shows
or flea markets the Saturday morning I
either went to my dad's liquor store to
work or I did a baseball card show the I
wouldn't call it a regret but in
hindsight the fact that I spent every
single free moment outside of school
from my freshman year of high school to
my senior high school 92% of that time
on working that number could have been
maybe 75 like I probably should have
went to a couple of more parties so like
slow down yeah notice how my number one
from 92 to 75 I probably should have
kissed a couple more girls I probably
should have got into a little bit more
trouble but I still I'm talking just a
little bit more I would never do it
differently it's who I was there was no
other option and that's such a minor
shift that I would never consider to go
back and change it but um I will say to
you you know getting the quick vibe I'm
getting from your dad understanding the
fact of your interviewing we were
sitting here the thing that you may want
to keep in the back of your mind from
this interview when you rewatch this
when you're 1416 just a little fun you
know
fun's important by the way fun if you
need it yeah like you know in truth I
didn't need it I didn't want it at all
there was never a time in my v from 15
to 25 prime years for fun and all that
stuff there was never one day one moment
one hour where I wanted to choose going
to the Jersey Shore and hanging out
going to a party going to a bar you know
going with my buddies on a road trip
never which is why I didn't do it every
time I did want to do it
hence the 92% the 8% play wiffleball go
to a party kiss a girl I did do it so I
think uh I think your biggest concern as
you get older is you want to make sure
you're doing things for yourself not to
make him proud and that's going to be
the toughest thing for you okay so the
third question is that like why you like
in New York and and why how do you think
like how you how do you think you're
going to lead up to behind them so I
like them so much because much like you
your heritage
I wasn't born in America I came here
when I was three and when I moved to
Edison New Jersey which was our Stanford
Connecticut
no more Queens no more Dover and like
dinner that kind of setting
I found friend
and I didn't speak English and I got it
I didn't speak English when I first you
know came to America and it was my first
kind of like American friends and the
first day I went outside the first thing
they were doing was playing football
with the old nerf footballs and one of
the kids asked me who my favorite team
was I didn't have one and he said you're
a New York Jets fan and I said okay I'm
a Jets fan this is literally how it
happened and because they accepted me
that was our thing right like now I had
acceptance and and this was me now
creating this story 15 years later it
took me a while to even like remember
how it even happened but my friends in
the neighborhood they were jet pants
because we didn't live here my dad my
uncle's my mom nobody else was jet to
any fans they made me jet bands I
started watching religiously I watched
all the time I loved football and it
just became my thing and somewhere
around third fourth grade somewhere
around the age Lloret now I realized
that I was more likely to buy the Jets
than to play for them as I started
looking around and realizing wakil Shaw
was going to be a much better football
player than me Dave Jennings was getting
a much better football player to me and
so I started realizing that's what I
wanted to focus on and I don't know how
I'm gonna buy the Jets I don't I do not
I know that I by nature as a businessman
and a counter-puncher what I mean by
that is oh karate do you do cloudy yeah
so I I don't know this because I don't
have never done karate but what I hear
by being a common sense individual in
the world is a lot of martial arts is
predicated on using other people's
energy as your offense right good that's
who I am as a businessman I'm the best I
think I'm going to go down as one of the
best karate businessmen of all time
because what I'm extremely good at is
responding to the actions of the market
and then finding my opportunities I
never thought that I would be producing
content that I would be into social
media that I would have an agency that I
would write books I reacted to the
opportunity got it yeah so there was no
plan the plan was pay attention to
what's going on
the opportunity and strike it so that's
all my gosh 20 questions quick job
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like
you
[Music]